[Music]
sean's in los angeles hi sean welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave dr john thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so i have been
and baby step two aggressively paying
off the only debt that i have which is
student loans for the last three months
good and um and i have been in the just
recently i was approached by
a really good friend and a member of my
church who
they felt impressed by the lord to gift
me a large sum of money towards the
student loan debt and it's something
i've been praying for privately to the
lord for
many many years now and the provision is
coming and so
my question is with this large sum of
money well i want to make sure that both
this person and i are both being wise
with it uh handling it
legally wisely and
if if we can't avoid any potential taxes
that may come from that what is the
amount of money
the amount of money is fifteen thousand
dollars okay and evidently i'm learning
that there might be more coming
okay he can do 15 000 individual to
individual in a calendar year
without any gift tax and without any
taxes at all okay if it's more than
currently that if it's more than that if
he's married his wife could give another
15 000. how much is your student loan
debt
i have about 60 000 left okay
so you are praying and asking god to
help you pay off the student loans he
sends fifteen thousand dollars what's
the question
i just want to make sure that we are
playing this wisely with taxes and doing
it legally because i want to make sure
that person is protected from any
horrendous taxes that may come from a
gift tax okay and make sure that maybe
i'm not getting taxed of the law you
have no taxes he has no taxes if it's
15.
if it's more than that there is more
coming which the plan is if there's more
than that it needs to be after the after
the calendar year ends or
is he married
uh this person is single okay then uh
there's uh
he's either gonna have gift tax on it if
it's more than that or he's gonna wait
on the first of the year
um
or he can seek a tax professional's
advice there's a thing called the
unified estate tax credit if his estate
is under 20 million dollars he can give
up some of his federal exemption for
estate taxes and avoid the gift tax that
way that does require one page form to
be filed
on anything over fifteen thousand and he
and he permanently loses part of his
estate
deduct federal estate deduction that is
not as susceptible to federal estate tax
but if his net worth is under 20 million
dollars then it's a non-issue and here's
another thing to think through sean
um
this person's a grown-up making grown-up
decisions and if their grown-up decision
to give you 25 000 means they got to pay
some taxes
i'm guessing if they're in a position to
write you a check for 25 grand they're
in a position to pay the tax on that
whatever so or in a position to get some
tax advice yes it's your responsibility
yeah don't don't beat yourself up take
the gift and then don't use it for
anything other than paying off your
student loans yeah because that's
exactly what you prayed for and if you
got it and then you gave something else
with it then you'd be like god's gonna
be going what yeah you know so that's
like struck by lightning kind of stuff
i think that's how that works but
probably not it feels fun in my head
i'll strike you with lightning oh whoa
and you have that power do you